his hands his energy now I go ahead and
I take that down he's pushing push push
push push push push push push push push
all that energy is going down I don't
need a
base energy just like I I can do it on
one leg well of course I can do it on
two without a base okay I'm not leaning
if you're not grounded when he pushes
you you will of course get pushing but
because you need a bracing angle
because you're not ground voring the
energy is not passing through you you're
stopping it here at the hand so you need
that foot okay when the energy passes
through you you don't need that foot
even to project him off again if he lets
go I should not go flying forward
because my energy is just going down he
lets go and I don't fly forward